doing good for other people is a good
strategy
[Music]
rain just went away beautiful day
Hey and I hope you'll reciprocate with a
send in this energy gone that is to with
spend it I don't wonder pretend that I'm
something I am NOT the trend but I wish
that was the general consensus Hey
Solano but I would think this is my
current POV because I think it's
actually important that I have a
different answer for this at 50 and 60
because you're going to adjust to the
reality I'll give you a good example if
something terrible happens in my life
and it's disease based or it's because
some kid was texting while he was
driving and hit my dad those will become
things that I want to leave a legacy
about because that's just how we accent
seems right they become your truth but
no question this will never go away I
want to do the following I'm fascinated
by the same thing that attracts so many
a millions of people to people that are
selling [ __ ] those same people are
attracted to me and what I want to do is
suffocate at all those other people and
become the Alpha of that entire world of
people that are hoping and are desperate
to look at me and what I want to do is
inspire two 14 year old girls in Kansas
City right now to build a billion dollar
company on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls I want
to build the biggest building in town
ever by just building the biggest
building in town while I think most
people try to tear down everybody else's
building so I think positivity and good
is practical advice to building an
empire and I want to be the poster child
of the person that built the biggest
Empire and did it by being a good dude
along the way end up taking months no
we're trying to help our leaders become
better business people because I believe
in them Lindsey right you get to work
with the Vayner talent she knows what
she's doing and she runs a tight PML but
then I'm always trying to break it you
know her it's a matrix for them right
because when they sit with Allan and she
financial they're trying to run a
business
but then I'll come over to talk to you
like no this is working hire more and
you're gonna have a negative PML this
year but they're like but Allan I'm like
[ __ ] Allan works for me and like you
know like it's a whole thing it's a
whole thing but it's been great because
back to pushing for opposite directions
I'm seeing it right I'm letting the
company do its thing but I'm a source
that's equal to the company of magic
right and I'm pushing and now I'm
starting to really figure it out
I'm kind of like almost really
separating them I'm even thinking like
things like a Gary tax right like if and
I'm basically that just offense right
that's Lindsey saying hey I really see
it I want to go for it and like cool you
know Gary taxes and so like well which
what that would mean is that she can
still run the business or her division
properly subtract the weird things I did
dollars wise and then see if she's
running an actual business I'm going to
secret meeting and I'll see you guys
later because what was happening was the
leaders were all under Gary tax and they
know how to run a business because my
halo being able to create top-line
revenue protected all their inabilities
and as we scale and I want to give them
other opportunities I needed them to be
able to be capable outside of magic
right like that [ __ ] back there
Michael Jordan he solved all of BJ
Armstrong's problems he made up for
horse Grant's shortcomings he wasn't
there those ones good anymore and so I
need to make sure that when I'm not
coming over the top and fixing
everything with my magic that they
actually know how to do something so
that my magic is added value not what
keeps us alive got it
I've never talked about that before
karma is practical I don't even think
Karma's like this is your thing doing
good for other people is a good strategy
like I like it's like you know I've been
like trying to forget I'm like why is
this thing even exist it's actually the
most common sense thing of all time why
weird the [ __ ] is karma like wait a
minute
so you're telling me like if you do lots
of good things that weirdly good things
happen for you yeah that's the only
common sense heading out big day
tomorrow all good stuff
CID rockfish I said I said to keep it
over my chest I'm Sean not the tall so
please will let us know that I'm
stressed I always say if you want to be
an anomaly you have to act like one like
people want all these special things to
happen but then they're acting like
everybody else and that gets into this
Saturdays on in your 20s like or or just
like taking risks or things of that
nature like I totally agree with you I
think about us you know that picture
where like it looks like two people
kissing or it looks like a glass of
champagne
like I just basically think at this
point in my business life the world sees
the glass of champagne and I see the two
people kissing
[Music]
the bonfire
[Music]